hearts are broken everywhere because
this is the fourth and final after movie
how satisfied do you think the fan base
will be with the Final Chapter
oh that's a tough one to call I hope
they'll be satisfied
um
yeah I hope they will I think for me
it's been kind of like a Bittersweet
happy sad but I kind of prefer to look
back and think I'm so happy and proud of
all the work we've done rather than
being sad about the fact that it's gonna
have to come to an end because it always
was going to have to come to an end but
yeah I I can only be hopeful
um that they love this last installment
and I'm pretty sure they will
and not many actors get to play the same
character for four films what are you
gonna miss the most about working on the
film and with your co-star Josephine
I guess I guess the character because
I've become so comfortable playing him I
feel like anytime you go play a new
character always takes like a day or two
to really really feel comfortable with
this set and learn everyone's names and
kind of feel at home there and with
Harden and after I have really learned
to feel really comfortable coming back
to play him and it doesn't feel like I'm
going to do a new role it feels like I'm
coming to do the same the same guy again
but just further in the story so yeah I
think I'll miss the familiarity of
playing this character
right I feel like we're in for a ride of
emotions for this next film I mean it's
going to be your relationship with
Tesla's going to be tested in a bigger
way
um what can you choose for our favorite
couple
oh um
it's hard to not spoil anything but I
think the thing that I enjoy most about
playing it and even watching it back is
how much more kind of adult the the
themes and issues that they deal with
are I mean it used to be about you know
like what you're going to do when you
first get to college and now it's about
like what you're going to do when you
need to find a job when you're still
chasing your dreams but you still want
to you know get bills paid and you know
your social social life after that and
even just seeing how they look different
having having grown up and and just
dealing with with with different issues
and the kind of things that adults deal
with it's so nice that we've been able
to continue this story through you know
adolescence through to like young
adulthood
and obviously there are a ton of steamy
scenes so I have to ask what goes
through your mind when you're watching
yourselves after the fact on screen in
these scenes
um I'm just looking at the tattoos
thinking oh that one was starting to rub
off but no one's gonna know and I
remember that I that was an hour away
from lunch and we were all really hungry
and yeah it's nowhere near as glamorous
or sexy as you would as you would think
it is unfortunately sadly it's all it's
all movie magic isn't it one shot works
for 10 seconds at the start and then you
fall on the bed and then we need another
camera setup so there's a 15 minute
break
um it's actually quite funny how sadly
the kind of the that romantic element
that comes to life in the film really is
movie Magic and um it's nowhere near as
kind of romantic as it as it feels in
the moment but you know that's that's
what the game's about and it's credit to
the editors and all the other
departments and how they can all you
know bring it together
well you did mention you know the
characters developing so much over the
course of all the films
um how do you think you personally have
grown as an actor
um through the course of the films
massively massively like I don't think I
could put it into words it is just like
such a blessing to be able to play the
same character so many times and
therefore really like work on the skills
rather than just being like okay I need
to figure out how this character should
be
it's almost like an acting exercise or
Workshop to play the same character so
many times as you really hone in on like
the the smaller more nuanced kind of
subtle subtle elements of acting so yeah
it's done so so much for me I'm so
grateful hopefully I can play a
different character because now
sometimes I take a different role and
I'm like oh God all I know how to do is
wear white and punch wolves and and get
into arguments and and stuff but no I'm
sure I'll be fine
I mean you have a lot of very exciting
roles coming up so you're going to be
fine but it's opportunity to return to
the franchise
um would come up in the future what
would you say would you do it uh would
depend on on a lot of a lot of things
I'm also aware that that all good things
may come to an end and it's like when
you do a little drawing and then you
want to add this bit and then that bit
and you take a step back and you're like
that was perfect how it was and I've
just done too much so I'm aware that
that can be a trap you can fall into but
maybe down the line in a little Cameo if
they do a spin-off it would be nice to
just come pay homage for a bit
um so yeah Never Say Never but we'll
have to see